i'm not sure if you're familiar there's
something called the simulation
hypothesis
well that's been fun to talk
about with the computer scientists and
so on which is a
kind of thought experiment that proposes
that um you know the entirety of the
world around us is a kind of a computer
program
that's a simulation and then we're
living inside it
i think there's um i think from a
certain perspective that could be
consistent
with a a religious view of the world
i mean you could just use different
terms basically
uh what are your but it's a it's a it
feels like a more
um modern updated version of that but
what is
what's your sense of this uh or the
simulation hypothesis do you find it
interesting
useful to think about it do you find it
ridiculous did you find it fun
what are your thoughts uh it's fun and
it's been of course the subject of
various movies yeah
um that that some of which are very well
known
um you know
i don't think it makes sense to think of
it as a simulation
hypothesis in the sense that we're
really
lying in uh banks um
of of uh on banks of
beds having our energy drained away from
us
and and the simulation is going on in
our individual brains
that that makes no sense to me at all i
don't think that's what's
meant by the simulation hypothesis as
you're using it now
but i think that there is a um
there is very little distinction between
saying
that a an intelligent creator
has set up the universe according to
his will and his plan
and set it in motion and is
allowing it to run out maybe as
christians say
he's sustaining it actually
um by his word of power it says in the
book
of the letter to hebrews okay um
in in in in this amazingly consistent
and um integrated way
um i don't think there's very much
difference between saying that and
saying that it's assimilation okay
i mean i think it's almost the same
thing okay
but i but i think from but i think it's
important to recognize that
the simulation in that concept the
simulation and the creation or the
or the universe are the same thing okay
in other words it's a simulation you
know that is
billions of light years across okay
yeah um i mean there's a sense in which
it helps
one understand especially if you're not
religious
that there's something outside of the
world that uh we live in
that there's something bigger than the
world we live in um
and that i mean it's just another
perspective on uh
that humbles humbles you um so
in that sense it's a possible thought
experiment one shortcoming of that
is is the following is of the of the
analogy
here's this that we think of a
simulation as something take
taking place in the universe you know
when we it's it's taking place in my
computer
okay i don't think that's the right
analogy for
a christian view of creation okay i
don't think it's
taking place in some other
universe that god has made okay i think
maybe it's taking place in the mind of
god
christians might hypothesize also but i
but i think that that
that it's important to recognize that
christian theology at a
at any rate is that god is not one of
the entities in the universe and
presumably therefore is very different
from a simulation that we might run on a
computer
you